crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
yeah you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know soccer star JUCO
above-ground cool goes better than most
Jade Lawson self-diagnose go down low
this week last week here we go again
[Music]
immediate jump on that pitch hmm it was
instant that was a pinch touch from Note
one all the way up until damn near the
very end sick well I mean you know this
plant was not know um you know what I
mean it really is
people they just can't do it like I
can't believe all the times we've done
us still getting pressed but you know
what it's always good
feasto nation always always always a
pleasure to be here with you Jay Larson
call me calm Jay Larson comedy on all
social media big thank you to everyone
who came out to Portland it was great to
be up there with you guys one of my
favorite cities Helium such a great club
they took such great care of me and it
was just awesome to see so many features
coming up to shows you guys rock belts
as I mentioned before down the road in
October the first be in October I'll be
at La La Jolla Comedy Store and that's
pretty much it I got some in town dates
and stuff but I'm kind of laying low but
sickle cell you ain't Ryan Sickler on
all social media Ryan Sickler com I
would like to say special thank you to
Tom Segura for let me perform with him
at the lyric in Baltimore that was a
fantastic show so many things had to
happen I was supposed to come back that
day and and thank you to every single
person that helped me out my brother
everybody that made that they didn't
even go a seven because they don't watch
if they all helped out man everybody
helped that was great so and tom has
great fans that was a hell of a show I
met quite a few fee stirs out in the
lobby so you guys are great thank you so
much for giving me some Baltimore love
that felt amazing almost 2,000 people
man it was great September 29th and 30th
four shows at the La Jolla comedy store
used code crab for two-for-one tickets
code crab you get two for one ticket to
record my album come on down for any and
all craft fees related information you
know you can go to the craft
komm there's so many ways to help the
podcast there's that free way we're not
allowed to tell you about anymore we
tell you about for years to dial back a
few episodes merch premium apps and make
sure you follow the crab feast on
Facebook and Twitter this week great
sponsor I've talked about it many times
blue apron who if you're not familiar
blue apron basically I'm gonna just give
it to you in layman's terms they deliver
food to your home with all the
ingredients you need to make amazing
recipes you can make meals for up to two
people or four people Kate and I we do -
we have those meet we have the meal then
we make the kids their kids meal you
don't have to if your kids a little
older you can do whatever you got to do
it's affordable for less than $10 per
person per meal home-cooked meal every
week you can pick different things
here's the thing that I love is they'll
put in what's in season you know I mean
like you bring it to pick but like
lately like cherry tomatoes were in
three of our recipes last week and it's
like things that you would just never do
when was the last time you took cherry
tomatoes you know those little round
Tomatoes and you're throwing them in a
pan with olive oil and cooking up with
like corn I made this never I forget
what the meal is yeah exactly my point
and that's what I'm doing I've done it
like three times and then I'm like
looking they have some meals here that
they're miso butter salmon and lo mein
noodles with cucumber and charm tomatoes
whole grain pasta with summer vegetables
an heirloom tomato caprese salad sauteed
shrimp and green beans with globe
tomatoes spinach and orzo pasta those
are some things that are like you can go
pick right now and it's because that's
what's in season that's what's popping
off and fresh right now it's the best
because you're making meals usually what
happened we get three meals every week
Kate and I and I'll open up the box and
I look and I'll pick I look at the three
recipes and I'm like I what's my
favorite one out of all these and I'll
make them and then the third one out of
the three you gonna have a least
favorite and everytime we cook that last
one we're like this is unbelievable why
you know what I mean right it's super
easy to do read helps out River helps
out we all cook together all the food is
substantive stainless fans
sourced sustainably understand is
developed in partnership with the
Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood Watch just
guys let me let me just tell you what
the deal is so you
have to worry about what I'm telling you
check our go check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free with
free shipping by going to blue apron
comm slash crab feast what what do you I
don't understand why you wouldn't where
it's free free food you're just gonna
get free great food great food free
fresh and here's the best so the other
day I went through and took all the
cards because they have a card that
shows you how to cook and what your
ingredients are and we've kept them all
we have over 80 recipes with so funny -
you got a bomb you got a binder of them
a Trapper Keeper baby Schools in session
bet you'll love how good it feels and
tastes create incredible home-cooked
meals and Bloor apron so do not wait
blue apron dot-com slash crab fees blue
apron Dhaka better way to cook blue
apron comm slash crappie that's right
I'll tell you who else we have this week
we got ProFlowers back as our one of our
favorites as always sent us a rose
bouquet recently mm-hmm I can't tell you
Thank You Pro flowers I can't unless
some somebody sent me roses no right I
was surprised you must've been surprised
I was very surprised assorted roses
beautiful bouquet just great for summer
nobody's ever sent me roses um well
that's the best thing about their
flowers too is they're gonna last yeah
like we say this all the time they
always last more than the seven-day
guarantee absolutely and ProFlowers
wants to help you surprise someone for
no reason at all while also surprising
you with a special deal for our
listeners get 20% off any of the unique
summer rose bouquets or any other
bouquet of twenty nine dollars or more
the colorful rainbow roses are always a
hit if you aren't sure what to send
anyone all right
or someone Pro flowers bouquets are
guaranteed to stay fresh as Jay Larson
said for at least seven days or your
money back and you control the delivery
date ProFlowers gives you more bloom for
your buck big beautiful flowers with
more stems for your money that's the
best thing we're saying right now if
there's some in your life you want to
surprise go right now and you can set up
whenever you want to to have it
delivered you know what if I was if I
knew I had terminal illness I would set
flowers to go when I knew I'd be gone
but like a month later yeah it's a great
idea
not if from ProFlowers girl to get 20%
off summer roses or any other bouquet of
$29 or more go to proflowers.com use our
code crab at checkout
that's proflowers.com code crab don't
wait to make someone's day and do not
wait for this week's episode because
it's a doozy
on a Tuesday excited to have her on
we've been trying for a long time the
best part is when you tell me you want
to have someone on I'm like I've been
thinking the same thing and that's what
was going down with this week's guests
ladies and gentlemen excited to have on
for the first time please welcome
[Applause]
I don't what should I get one yes just
because I want to see if the clapping
works I've heard it's a rumor and you go
to bed at night these a little just
strap it to your pet let it run around
and get you extra steps if you're in
competition with people an outdoor
cabman nocturnal cats get an outdoor cat
those little bear won't come back they
don't know but you know what you put
that little collar on them come back
with like extra steps maybe a birdie
some [ __ ] well thank you so much for
being here
yeah we've been waiting to do this with
you here this is very exciting I don't
believe that but I like that you're one
of us Boston rise Marilyn you got that
Philly thing yeah and it's that like you
know but specifically when you said
where are you from she said South Philly
she didn't say filling she also shanked
me in anger apologize no worries well
once I put the adidas suit on it's like
a launcher suit for us we were saying
she came ready days you got the poof up
front by the hoop
fishtailed that Camaro right in the
[ __ ] parking lot
I certainly am are you what you know
t-tops are in the backseat Jack what a
CVD drop every date I've been on you
hear this how are we gonna make out back
there to back my life is to you come
second behind the data no wait wait let
me I want to hear all about we got a ton
to talk about you before we do please
promote yourself all right you know what
though I do know it you're right I
should be more confident myself I am
gonna be in Philadelphia August nice
that's what I'm saying
boom tomorrow August 9 yes I'm doing
warm daddy's which is on Delaware Avenue
very exciting that's the black Club I'm
working on because I I spread myself
equally then on August 10th I'm roasting
Pete Rose which is very exciting
don't be on a the 11th and the 12th of
yet the comedy works not in Denver not
the cool one I'll be in bristol PA
Comedy Works I didn't know that one no
soap not a lot of people do hopefully
you guys come out and show that it's a
real place thanks guys August 16th I'll
be a parks casino another great
establishment yeah that's a killer spot
actually oh yes it's a casino outside
Philly there's not outside it's in
Northeast Philly oh cool
yeah it's a nice
cute little area and then I'm at the La
Jolla comedy store August 25th and 26
some great dates get out there and see
her
thank you I'm trying I'm trying to get
out can I just say one thing about Pete
Rose before we move on please
adrián beltré just hit his three
thousands hit he's only the 31st person
to ever do it only 31 I've ever hit
3,000 Pete Rose hit a career worth more
than that yes it's the same thing that
records never get much can i brag about
something sure
my nephew little Jimmy Carrigan just got
drafted to the Minnesota Twins Wow
tonight can i brag about something oh
please look who's right here he hit
tonight he hit a two-run homer this was
a farm team it's the Colonel's car he
plays left field right now but he he's
your right hand Lefty he's a righty he
moved around he was in right field he
was a catcher because he was little for
a while but then he got a scholarship to
Temple and they cancelled the baseball
program and he was playing right field
and then they cancelled the baseball
program it was a sophomore year I'm so
cool
yeah well University I got rid of a few
of those sports programs and then he got
picked up by VCU so he played for love
so he's playing a ramp for them yes the
ramps very good and they were one game
out of the World Series so I gotta watch
him on ESPN like three years how'd he do
in the yeah what's what round two get
drafted him he didn't that's the worst
part that happened so when he graduated
he didn't get picked up and he was like
it's over so he finished his degree he's
a conditioning and strength coordinate
yeah whatever whatever coach whatever
it's called and so he was he finished
his degree in that but he was playing in
different leagues then he got picked up
by a Missouri team and he was playing
for them a minor league ball club and
when he went in to play the other night
I think it was Thursday night he was
starting like it he was leading off I
mean and then they took it down
they cross his name off and he's like
why he goes Jeremy they just bought your
contract you got sold to the Minnesota
Twins yeah a little South Philly kids
doing good Jimmy Kerry get Jay Kerrigan
I think it is j ke r RI GA ni mo and
your and your your cousin Nancy who's my
town I'll tell you this her we're not
related to we would never get beat up
Philly's curling up on the floor and she
would throw a skate skate off and slice
her and her boyfriends throat right on
that ice and then and then one mighty
tops you understand no way that whatever
I drove by a Nancy's house when I was
home two weeks back I was with my mom
hold on
is it her current home or her left child
it was is it a museum or somebody lived
there yeah yeah it's a museum right we
wait for the docent to take us through
[Music]
you better watch your [ __ ] mouth oh
sorry are you big Nancy Kerrigan she
went to my high school [ __ ] did she cry
there too [ __ ] self filming I just
don't like that you don't beat up at
Kerrigan
that's ridiculous don't get mad at her
sure being such a thing yeah you don't
get beat up it never happens yeah she
should have had some family members
waiting in the wings like a fever - you
got out of line they would just show up
you'd be [ __ ] your pants so I wanted
to ask we want to ask you we have a lot
I'm done I'm
I'm in you have how many brothers and
sisters I have six brothers and three
sisters there's ten of you ten of us in
a South Philly borough home how many
bedrooms two and a half my mom will say
it's three bedrooms [ __ ] she always say
it's three bedrooms it's not three
bedrooms that's a glorified closet did
your parents get their own room yes
right you see well I'll tell my dad left
when I was seven I was eight I was
probably eight so when he left my little
sister Edie was sleeping with my mom and
then she said that I used to walk the
hallways and be like mom where am i
sleeping tonight my sisters would let me
sleep in there because they had she put
it in that glorified closet she put a
canopy bed you could barely open the
door they had a wedge it open and like
you know shimmy in yeah I lived in Rome
in Baltimore in the room I had had a
twin bed in it and a dresser that's it
that's all but I had to turn sideways to
slide in between the best and read down
on it and turn to get on it and off it
like that yeah I can't imagine I mean
how the canopy [ __ ] used to open like
you know jump back I'd be like what the
[ __ ] was that
that's not was attacking is it she's
like I want it my little girls like oh
you should have thought of that after
you know yeah what the hell what is what
happened on the tenth Ennead I was like
alright I'm out well because my dad won
at 12 and then after Tammy was like whoa
this is a lot so he had ten really like
you know what this is bad this was a bad
I did he bounced all together Oh is he
still in the picture he moved like a
couple blocks away sometimes I see my
dad but we were still close with him he
just didn't pay any child support or
anything he owns a typewriter stories
[ __ ] crazy a typewriter store listen
guys there's no read to co-rect girl
that's how he yells at me
you'll see computers were only a phase
no no no he closed it probably been like
seven years now okay but he I mean it
was like I will tell you this when I got
married we had a typewriter like for
everyone to like sign in on you know an
old typewriter
it was my Nana's typewriter what was
what kind loyal maybe probably but I had
to get it like tuned you know I mean
like doors down but a place you know you
had to find someone that could do that
there's very few people that can still
do that you should have called me I grew
up in that typewriter store yeah guy
tried to sell me word processing when I
wasn't I'm like man I'm [ __ ] right in
but he's trying to get ahead of
themselves process came over the balls I
be em selector tree yeah we used to have
to respawn ribbon all day because here's
the thing might he put you to work and
yeah and we were little like me and my
brother what's the oldest to youngest
this is the worst part we're only 15
years apart away and my mom took a
two-year break between Johnny and Jimmy
which is numbers whoa whoa four or five
holy [ __ ] I don't know maybe she felt
like maybe I shouldn't do this and then
she was like let's get to it so she
didn't work she didn't work and my dad
yeah ten Birds I like make a joke on
stage that she had a hysterectomy and
when they took the uterus out there was
still kids in it and she was let's just
take on right so you guys were an
orphanage you were they were still
together for all ten kids yeah Johnny's
20-some years they already got 20 years
it's not like that my mom's sister had
ten kids - holy doing me yes we are part
of the problem I get it
um how does that even work tank it like
what do you have for dinner
Oh like what kind of kitchen how big was
a kitchen teeny tiny still my mother
even
when we go home she's like I'm not
cooking I know exactly the size we lived
in a three-bedroom one she still lives
in the same house put it this way I was
just one bathroom one and a half we had
a powder room
my uncle Tommy insisted on putting a
powder room yeah twelve people with one
bathroom but if you flush that toilet
downstairs somebody's [ __ ] upstairs
yeah but like I was the other day I was
at Whole Foods getting like ham right
and I'm getting hand but you look
through from the where they do the cold
cuts into the kitchen and they get those
giant pots where they're making all the
prepared food you know like they're just
hanging like like Navy pots how are you
that's okay I mean you had to right yeah
and you did have a dining room table
where did you you know we had a tape
then there was like a bench and I
remember the bench was broken so if you
sat on it wrong you pinched your back
like all of us have scars also in the
room because this is what happened my
sister I was a bed-wetter sorry
whatever probably nerds at night well
you're a better that and my brother
Tommy and Karen became in charge of us
because my mom had to get a real job
because numbnuts was playing with
typewriters so she had to pay she had
she had a fetus so she was a secretary
at the Philadelphia Navy shipyard so she
had like a real job and she used to be a
beer girl for the Phillies and Eagles
like just to keep the house basically so
they became the older half became in
charge of us and I'm number eight so
Tommy and Karen my older brother and
sister would put us to sleep Tommy was
obsessed with Alice Cooper so he used to
act out welcome to my night with the
makeup like and I'd be in bed like might
be so scared to get up that I would just
became whatever so I was a bed-wetter
have you ever listened to welcome to my
head I know exactly if you know the
lyrics to only women bleed at eight
years old it's not it's not good it's
not good no nobody does this I mean like
we're like you know we both have young
kids so we had to go through sleep
training and all that crap or like
getting your kids to sleep and
do that [ __ ] hello would you get any kid
like what time are you going to bed wait
I think the fresh depression set in so
we were just like sleepers place to
sleep he's inviting us to his nightmare
I just wet my brother Charlie was a bed
wetter too and this is what we had in
the room I swear to god it was a triple
bunk bed a double bunk bed I mean a
little bit triple like I saw one online
today but would you modify really it was
you know I'm the only reason I know that
they came on and off easily it's because
for a while there we put my brother
Bobby in the middle bunk because he
would have nightmares and then I was wet
in the bed so they moved me down the
bottom with Charlie so me and Charlie
were sharing a bed we both went to bed
we almost drowned it was awful and
finally my mom somebody gave her a
mattress so she put a mattress
underneath the Bronco yes but it didn't
have like a yeah a real I would pull
that out and sleep on that so I didn't
have to do I didn't have to get beat up
on my brothers for whatever so more kids
on that bed so there was so Jimmy Murray
stack and bought you Billy and then
Johnny and Charlie she finally was able
to buy the double bunk bed that also had
drawers in it which we thought we hit
the line [ __ ] we slept in those drawers
I gotta be honest like we were like so
Bobby Charlie and Johnny were over there
Tommy had his own bunk and so Jimmy
Bobby Billy and then me but Bobby was
having a nightmare that he was stuck in
you know those cellars that open like
this though yeah yeah yeah fly open we
didn't know how shelter yeah we didn't
know there was a grace to a basement did
so when we were little we used to run on
them cuz they made fun noise and you
know until the break guy came up and
almost killed us we didn't know
down there but yeah so Bobby his best
friend used to have a basement and they
used to sneak in that way and he was
having a dream that he was not stuck in
there and so he started kicking and he
kicked my brother Jimmy out of the bed
and it went it missed him that wood
thing nearly went right through his head
oh [ __ ] because those are heavy it was
all metal heavy ass wood and it went off
and Jimmy went flying across the room
onto the single bunk bed I mean the
single bed where Tommy was and they were
like what the [ __ ] my mom did it how
many of you went to college the two - I
went but I dropped out okay
my sister Kathleen tried to go for a
little bit I mean they're [ __ ]
defensive line holding her yeah pretty
much she got bored she got bored she
would take courses she got bored 30% you
dropout brought it down to 20 yeah my
bait my older brother Tommy is super
smart when he might not be related
I don't know happen the rest of us had
paint chips and then Edie's good and she
graduated Wow
so the baby in the eldest pretty much
the rest of us are all just saying we
got all the love next to your mom and
that bed help you graduate school yes
she wasn't getting one rubbed out on her
I mean yeah yeah she wasn't listening to
the white noise that I had a listen to
mom's coming home with [ __ ] Billy
beer all over she would always be late
for work and she'd be running we only
lived like a mile from the stadium so
she'd be late for work and she'd be
running and Dick Vermeil with the birds
he used to run around the stadium all
the time so she'd run past and she got
high Dickey and he just terrified lady
I guess that beer lady said oh yeah she
wasn't in the c-section at all
[Music]
yeah that's all badge right there that's
all I mean is your mom asleep sweet
what's her deal
probably the greatest person I've ever
met my I mean it takes a certain kind of
like even now I see with my friends who
are moms moms like friends that our moms
are like these people some of them some
of them just wanted to be moms and you
can tell it's innate in them not just
innate because you're a woman and they
cause they're like I can have my kids
running crazy I still have the meals I'm
you know what I mean to have [ __ ] all
organized she must have had good lord or
they're like your dad my mom where some
people like to have kids but don't on
like the kids well your mom did have a
choice right and my dad got beat her to
the punch
she was fried next in line to get out of
there yeah he's got some heavy swimmers
but he like he yeah he's [ __ ] dead on
I mean that's that's not easy and she
had a miscarriage like her first she was
frightening 11 time yes she told me she
only had sex 10 times and I'm like what
about the miscarriage and she's like
okay only had sex tender first of all
very Catholic very crazy
when did they think to just like maybe
just [ __ ] pull yeah have a good time
let a little splash on the back
calm down Eleanor she's like god damn it
that Eleanor like so she she's the
sweetest lady she never was amazing that
she has such animal children you that
are cool yeah you didn't even need to do
open mics you know what I mean like
you're just ready to roll after that
[ __ ] right yeah I mean I people used to
say that like how come you're not doing
Santa cuz I was waitress at the store
for like 12 years
yeah and never like how came out doing
stand-up and I'm like stop trying to
pull me into your [ __ ] miserable life
yes let me be I'm an actress I'm busy
I'm doing other things yeah
I'm gonna take over for Meryl Streep but
she's like my best friend was Freddy
Soto I don't know if you guys know know
Freddy he was I didn't really know him
personally either cuz I got to the store
shortly after I mean surely before he
passed but still to this day one of my
favorite things I've ever watched is in
Spanglish remember when the guy goes hey
man can you translate for me or the mom
and he looks at you and he goes uh yeah
[ __ ] Mexican yeah he's so funny but
anyway he he would be like why are you
not doing stand-up why every time I come
see you in a play you just got raped by
the football team they ripped a
stillborn child out you have to [ __ ]
mourn it she must be at that they must
have just threw her in the pack yes he
would freak out like why are you doing
comedy I'm like I just don't he's like
tell those stories you tell about your
brothers you know stupid [ __ ] cuz I go
home a lot and we all like nobody left
I'm the only one that left they either
lived up the street or around the corner
from my mom and she lives in the same
house that I grew up in yeah there's
three that live in the suburbs I can't
tell you why most of them are racist
reasons but I'm just kidding they did it
to better the schools you to go to
better schools because we had to go to
Catholic school because the public
schools were so bad but the Catholic
schools were worse like I went to an
all-girl Catholic High School and there
was a girl in my school that got busted
for selling like she was like the number
one dealer and then in Philadelphia yeah
how old were you and you got your first
job because you must have been like
eight or something I was eight you're an
[ __ ] I had a word for my dad when he
left he would we were like hey we need
money and he like well you gotta work
for it girl oh my gosh
[ __ ] so he made I mean I'm sorry my
brother Billy wear the clothes we're
very close in age we're not the closest
we're just how old is the closest 10 is
this how much longer for this heals up
yeah cuz we got to fill it I mean that's
crazy to make my car tonight right
really yeah my brother Bobby has Irish
friend for a month and a half there's
they're the same age what me yeah
Bobby's my brother Bobby's kids for a
month and a half to the scene I just
picture you like look at the wife like
oh really the husband he's like you know
what that's like a loving couple or just
the dude who's like [ __ ] I'm getting
my yeah he figured it out right after
and they haven't had any kids since so
but it took him a minute you know I was
like Bing Bing and then he's like let's
shut this down but yeah so we like I had
to work for my dad because my mom had to
get a real job so we had to go to the
typewriter store every day after school
and I remember me and Billy or Hunter
and we're yeah I'm 8 he's 9
you know we're that close so he's my dad
laughs my dad left and my brother I
think my brother Johnny was in charge
like Hughes he was answering the phones
we couldn't do that part and so he goes
you to swab the deck and he left and we
were like what the [ __ ] so we don't know
what that meant and we had to call my
mom at work and be like hey we don't
want to lose our lives this afternoon
mrs. Carey section 40 TV yeah that's
free [ __ ] that's a ship terms by the way
he's a Marine okay okay at 8:00 you
wouldn't know right I don't know
don't think I wouldn't I doubt it I was
terrified I had no idea and then and
then I remember like there were times
when it was Tommy Jimmy
me and Billy at the typewriter store and
like Tommy like I told you he would put
us to bed with Alice Cooper [ __ ] so he
listened he's he's our Archie brother if
you will right so he would be like I got
an idea and he made Billy sit in the
chair and he thought he was an amazing
artist by the way but he'd draw a
perfect picture of an apple and he put
it over Billy's head and then he throws
darts at him and Jimmy and then somebody
somehow somebody named Jimmy laughs and
Jimmy is you know his sons the one that
got trapped like picked up by the twins
cuz they're monsters right Jimmy's got
ridiculous strength him and my sister
Karen have [ __ ] strength sorry if
we're not allowed to say that but I said
it
so Jimmy threw the thing and he was a
little bit off and it hit a spray paint
can and it spray paint went all over
this maniac my father was he has shot me
quite a few times this time it was gonna
be for real yeah we were like [ __ ] we
were like we are dead
we I mean he kicked our asses so we were
like for sure we are dead and we all
just started cleaning but my grandfather
his father made tools specifically for
typewriters never marketed them because
that would be yeah why why would really
have to move out of money you what kind
of person you're supposed to love yeah
so yeah so he it was all those tools
were covered we were like [ __ ] so we're
cleaning tool I mean it was just we've
we got out of it you did yeah we cleaned
it we're very hard-working people when
we have to be is that when the OCD was
born pretty
terrifying you know anxiety all that
[ __ ] kicks in amazing my dad did shoot
me with a rifle one time as a goof I was
and sometimes I tell the story yeah okay
so he's a Marine there's too many we
need the best base yeah they wouldn't
notice yeah I can't afford to triple
bunk he so I came in and he was like
cleaning out a rifle and like as a joke
I was like hey dad don't shoot but I was
in like tenth grade at this point so I'm
already used to this [ __ ] in his
crazy ways and hey pull this pin because
he had grenades and [ __ ] I'm like
[ __ ] crazy man
so but he made one into a lighter
lighter he had because he was a Korean
War yeah so he stole grenades from
military and then he had ones that had
detonated that he kept and took home but
he would clean him up and make him look
really cool and he put a [ __ ] lighter
in the market of the [ __ ] out of that he
made me pull it and I was like you know
and I'm terrified but I do what he says
because he's giant man and it was a
lighter these are kind of jokes he does
you know what I mean it's not yeah did
he smoke cigarettes he wasn't a stand-up
What did he say correct he did for years
and years Terry ten cigarettes but he
quit like cold turkey no big deal really
mm-hmm
I don't know how he did that but he did
but that day when he was cleaning out
the rifle he was like a girl hold that
pencil up I bet I could shoot it out of
your hand and I'm like no no no what
happened I called it up and so I held it
and then he fired and I it was so loud
like I threw the pencil and I just don't
understand then I was like checking for
holes and he um I heard him laughing and
I'm like you know it's a [ __ ]
laughing it and he's like I got your
girl and I go what do you mean you got
me I'm like what do you mean you got me
I don't know what you're saying he's
like I got you I shot you with blanks
and I'm like oh my god on stage
sometimes if I do a story I'm like
finally ten kids later this prick is
shooting blanks but but at the same time
he did do it that day I was like
shivering the whole day and Olli one
time he did it in front of her friend
from LA and he was like this close with
a 45 and I saw the fire and I'm like dad
stop that they're not gonna understand
you well no one understands no you have
to understand him he's crazy yeah
clearly they took all his weapons away
now cuz he's 81 who took them every
night he's a total co2 rifle yeah he's
got that and he's killing birds
he's killing black birds I don't know
what kind of racist where does he do he
lives in Rehoboth Beach okay I was just
I was just there
do you know what it was at Funland
[Music]
he calls lesbians girl [ __ ] hey hey
girl there's a lot of girl [ __ ] out
here no worse than the men girl like
what I was there yeah yeah that's where
he is now yeah it's a gated little area
though they don't let him out of yeah
that's probably best the people prison
but no yeah him and his wife the girl
the lady he left my mom for he's still
where did you get her pregnant oh no no
probably she would throw herself down
some steps there oh she doesn't seem
kid-friendly
she like we never like how to sleep over
let's go let's go hang with daddy's
house you know it was never that never
ever and I think like he would take us
to McDonald's or like that was the only
time we have fast food cuz he would pick
us up every Thursday night and my food
my dad pick up whoo all of us all of
them in what in what a suburban a big
giant blue one yeah and we would
all in it everywhere you know back then
right that's that's a tight car yeah but
we were just but it was like Tommy
didn't have to go Karen didn't have to
go Catholic they were all working real
jobs at that point sir
Karen at Tommy there were 12 know
they're in high school they're 10 years
older at 11 years old yeah you know
Tommy's 11 years older than me Karen's
10 and then it just goes evenly but I
think it was like Johnny and down would
go to dinner with him yeah the rest of
them had like real jobs and [ __ ] they
had to do so they didn't give a [ __ ]
they were like whatever guy dad not
shoot me I'm sick of that guy he would
take us to like this this local pizza
place or McDonald's or Burger King and
that was it and we'd all eat and he'd
take us home and that was our time and
he did that for about maybe maybe a year
maybe two oh that's right after the
divorce I mean yeah yeah it didn't last
long
yes it started with like here's 20 bucks
girl go order a pizza
look you don't even want to see all
right I'll go but we didn't care we were
just like [ __ ] it
20 bucks ordered a pizza we were we all
started like if my mom would come home
she maybe leave like a couple dollars on
the table like go get yourself something
I'm too tired yeah I can't do it and you
know that happened a lot like we used it
Caesar because she would go I'm going
upstairs to change my shirt and then she
wouldn't come back but that's you know
yeah grand hog day for her [ __ ] man I
don't know how she did it
honestly no I don't either and trouble
like that yes there was some pretty
close calls and she yeah she I am sure
my mom was single mama when I was two
with four yeah and I was literally we
were out to dinner the other night me
and my wife we have two kids and I loved
her I go can you imagine my mom was
doing this with four and this chick
[ __ ] double and a half over there we
were not we we very very rarely went out
to eat like with my mom
she was like I'll just cook at home like
and you just see the big pot like you're
saying listen I'm not saying she was
responsible but I'm saying tell them you
know coming home a beer and hot dog
great story I don't know I mean cuz you
guys are sports guys this was something
my mom did that was probably my favorite
story and my most amazing memory kinda
as a kid by the way she could have
filled an American League team with the
DEA yes well we're gonna tell you this
we were it was bad snowstorm and
Philadelphia really really bad they
wouldn't let they were like if you can
get out they on the radio because my mom
was obsessed with the Flyers so she was
like she didn't work for them yes no but
she watched every game like if the dukes
of hazzard were on and the Broad Street
Bullies were on too bad Dukes of Hazzard
bullies are going right
so we had to watch the Broad Street
Bullies like all the time so I was like
here she goes with her game it was on
the radio and they said if you can get
to the spectrum we will let you in for
free I give you hot dogs and hot
chocolate and my mom was like wrap him
up he was going how far were you from a
mile okay like a mile a little over a
mile mile and a half and she put us on a
[ __ ] sled me Billie Johnny and
Charlie Karen had to stay home and watch
she was very upset because she wanted to
go out with a boy for Rudy Valentino but
that's a real seat top she really had a
boyfriend a Rudolph LT yeah anyway so
Rudy who did to take her out but my mom
said no you're not going out tonight you
have to watch the kids
the little ones Bobby needy so me Billy
Charlie and Johnny went to the game and
me and Billy were on a sled and I
remember I was in the front Billy was in
the back and for a while Billy had
fallen off and I'm like mom mom
[Laughter]
it's frostbitten over there no he's not
there anymore when you got there she
took him in we had the best jolly Johnny
walked just me and Billie she drugged
and then you know it was weird on the
four kids by herself - how are you how
was it pretty empty in there funny
people know the [ __ ] spectrum yeah I
was a little I was like Savin it made my
dad hadn't left at this point but he
wasn't back from work he was cheating
and seven but my I was like six or seven
when she did this and she I mean she was
just like she loved the Flyers they're
giving out free hot dogs and hot
chocolate I can't afford tickets to the
Flyers
my brother Charlie Johnny cuz they they
were like obsessed with Rick McLeish and
Reggie leach like that was their guys
they used to fistfight over them who was
better so we they were like like jumpin
around me and Billy were just we didn't
give a [ __ ] you know we were right there
against the glass and there was a
somebody got checked Bobby Clarke
checked this guy I think it was st.
Louis I think I'm playing st. Louis and
the guy was like blood coming out and
Billy was like just looking at him like
the [ __ ] doing you know and then
Billy just got a little bit like like
nauseous and Bobby Clarke just started
smiling my mom's like the weirdest why
is this yeah NHL in the 70s man yeah and
it was like the end of their you know
killer streak basically right because
they were already kind of that's bad
yeah it was killer
it was also you've been around sports a
long time so I want to talk to you about
I want to ask you so many questions
about the sport you got involved in
because there was a video on Facebook
that I saw and I really was like is that
really her and is that really real
rainbow yes double penetration double
penetration
you've just posted or someone else post
somebody made it for me my friend Katie
at the improv I didn't believe that I
used to wrestle and so I keep giggling
you have to wrestle okay clear but
clearly this first of all I was like I
didn't know being with my brothers
always always athletic extremely
athletic and we watching a lot of
wrestling back then with them Pacquiao I
mean we used to put like a flat sheet on
the floor and think like that was going
to pretty great that's the man yeah just
jump off a couch and you know go down my
brother Johnny one time playing a game
he went through the front window kind of
it wasn't good we did a lot of stupid
stuff like you know any mean like and
any time you got in trouble and my mom's
house like it was oh you're in trouble I
mean anytime you got hurt they would say
you got in trouble because we didn't
have I mean she had insurance but it
wasn't like well the full coverage it
was like gonna cost so I remember Jimmy
put hammered a nail through his thumb
and he came home like holding it and my
sister Kathleen left him she's like oh
you're in trouble and that my mom had to
take him to the doctors in a red wagon
can you imagine like bumping with a son
named anyway so so we always wrestled
but we always wear like cautions not to
get hurt except for that some of the
idiot kids and what we were like oh
don't get hurt you know so we would
wrestling was our favorite because they
were like oh it's fake you know so we
taught ourselves how to like hit each
other and not get hurt whatever
so then flash to like years later I'm in
LA trying to replace Meryl Streep and I
get an audition and it's at a hotel room
and you're like Cheryl Street
[Laughter]
wait so hold on how do you find out
about it somebody I just I got a friend
of mine was a producer on it or an
assistant to the producer and she was
like you should call it my friend she's
really athletic and
then I get the audition and I'm like
really a wrestling show and at first I
kind of like glow I didn't know we were
really gonna have to wrestle I thought
it was like a TV show so was glow about
already in existence the guy I wrestled
for his name is David we he also he also
started glow okay so he started glow and
what else he glow was his first like he
loves wrestling's from Indiana and he
like that was his thing and we were out
in the parking lot I asked you a few
because Daniel Van Kirk turned me on to
glow and I watched it sex marriage yeah
I did I really married fantastic it's
really good yeah I brought I thought you
wrestled for glow no and that's when you
said all the [ __ ] do things because
that was the mid 80s I was high school I
didn't know in my defense I couldn't
place what year I was a kid should I
just watched it so I was a kid watching
glow right so this was 99 mm okay and so
so I go in David ran into I brought him
to the comedy store to see my show a
couple weeks ago and Marc Maron was on
so he went up to Marc and he started
talking to he's like you're the guy
you're the guy who started glow he's
like am i playing you and Marta David's
like no but you're doing a hell of a job
for the idiot that you're playing like
so mark felt like validated he's like oh
my god really and so I mean whatever
he's awesome dude I still work for him
because I do commentary for WoW women of
wrestling you do she wasn't in our group
no now do you want to ask my wrestling
name well no we're good but if you could
just I'm kidding all right hold on no I
have let's start right this is Wow so
wow so you get the audition I get the
antenna and okay so know me its suplex
guys but wait hold on is it is this
going to be a show or is this going to
be a link at that point I didn't know no
I had no idea and my friend was just
like just do it just do it so now I'm at
The Comedy Store waiting tables and
I think it was like Freddy Soto Joe
Rogan like we were all just hanging out
in the car the kitchen and I said man
they want me to go to this audition and
it was Freddy's wife that worked for him
at the time so she was Freddy was like
man you should just do it you should
just do it so I'm like okay whatever and
then Joe was like yeah just make up a
character so we started like everybody
started making up characters and
naturally I have a baseball bat in my
car yeah a few of them and they're in
the Camaro sometimes it hits the t-tops
I come in the kitchen with this baseball
bat and I start hitting everything and
like yelling things like I remembered
from when I was a kid yeah so I'm like
doing all this stupid [ __ ] and they're
like yes do that channel your father and
I'm like oh my god they're gonna kick me
out they're not gonna [ __ ] keep me
you know so I go in there I do that I
scare the [ __ ] out of them I'm like
there now what did you go in dress did
you dress up or anything no I just want
jeans and a t-shirt did you share your
character in there at that point I just
was doing what I thought I didn't even
think of that but like I like I was just
thinking of the guys I liked growing up
and I I can't and you're just one of
these people think of a girl
really that's how weird it because in my
head I was thinking like Andre the Giant
you know we have you know we have sizes
you're gonna read can you know yeah it's
just like crazy and you're just doing
all this [ __ ] in front of it like people
submit a tape or something there's there
a Matt as there she what I felt like
that I felt like just [ __ ] do it you
did in the kitchen of a comedy store and
what you guys used to do in the living
room and talk [ __ ] like you do with your
brothers yeah so that's what I was doing
and they called me and they were like
hey would you be interested in doing
this wrestling show and I was like yeah
okay side nothing-- first is stop Warner
dolls and David
I paid that and then I went and it came
out of my first check but yes so I was
like well what is this until what is
this yeah so of course they told I go
[ __ ] I don't know if I could be arrests
they're like yeah just come in for the
training see if you like it you'll like
it you'll like it so I'm like alright so
now I have to call my mom
who had four boys in a row and this
little girl that all she wanted was a
girl and I played Rumble fumble in my
communion dress I mean I had a penis
since the day I'm like I just never did
girl things so now I have to call her as
I'm trying to become Meryl Streep and
tell her I'm gonna take a wrestling job
right so I'm like mom honey I'm gonna be
there I'm like selling beer up in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations you are in Section D and
I wish it went that well I gotta be
honest what happened I call her up and
I'm like mom please don't get mad at me
[Music]
it's great it's true she probably did
have one of us behind that stand so but
yeah so we so I call her up I'm like hey
mom don't get mad at me I'm gonna take
this gig it's a wrestling show she's
like oh honey I'm so happy for you my
quiet yes I'm really happy for you I go
mom it's a wrestling show and I'm on a
cell phone that's you know 17 years ago
so I'm like there's no way she's
understanding what I'm saying so she
goes Ellenor they have great women
characters on that show I am so happy
for you I'm like
the foxy on dad had a copperhead I think
so I hang up I go mom and call you back
when I get home calling from a landline
cuz you know 17 years ago cell phones
whatever yeah so um I get home I call
her up and I'm like my sister Karen
answers and she's like yeah you're gonna
be on West Wing that's [ __ ] my mommy
told everybody it took me 15 minutes to
get home
yes [ __ ] [ __ ] called everybody yeah
told her I was going to be hanging out
Martin she oh my god I'm like mom I
think of you on Martin Sheen I'm gonna
have a woman with a mullet and sleeper
hold
oh when she figured out it was wrestling
honey I got the extra point let me call
you back at half time
Petros just hit a double goin egg honey
I can't ya see that's what she did to me
I swear to God that she saw it alright
so then what happened like you went to
the Train I go to the trainee I'm
chain-smoking at this point I'm not
healthy
like I'm twenty seven twenty twenty
seven years old twenty-eight something
like that and so it's ninety nine twenty
seven so yeah so I'm chain-smoking I'm
not paying attention to health or
anything there like that one of the two
girls that are training us or walking as
I'm
smoking at the top of the hill at the
forum because that's where we trained at
the England the for me what I am
yeah it was killer so you know like well
and your sports fan so you appreciate
that the sparks were training like the
so Michael Cooper was their coach yeah
it was like thrilled I was like oh we'd
be like we would train with the sparkly
Lisa Leslie they would come watch us we
would go watch I mean it was awesome it
was [ __ ] anyway so yeah I'm
chain-smoking and they're like it's to
woman from the south who are absolutely
amazing
Selena majors and Peggy Peggy Lee
leather you know that goes back to Alice
Cooper he did he creeps some [ __ ] better
off if they would just molested us on a
regular I'm sorry alright too dark so
but yeah so now I'm wrestling and I'm at
the wait so what happened so yeah it's a
league and I'm comedy women it's at this
point forty whoa because they were
cutting it down to 25 I believe oh yes
so we they were cutting there were more
than they needed yes I'm a little
surprised we were cutting listen this
Eleanor's got a hell of a DDT but she
have you heard her monologue I was the
worst in the group no way they would run
and I'd be [ __ ] miles behind them
with cigarettes falling out coughing up
blood like what the [ __ ] did I get into
I'm just looking for a street fight I
don't do this
I am a street fighter not you know let
me get out of here so I'm just a my put
me in a bunk bed match right off the top
on somebody I don't care but this is
ridiculous this was really hot like
really trying to weed him out dude
so I mean I make Selina and Peggy laugh
really hard by [ __ ] on people cuz I
know I'm getting cut so now I'm just
[ __ ] on everybody that walks in and
though it's to her laughing so hard
when David McClane the owner tried to
cut me they were like oh hell no we meet
her really she's funny yeah and I was
like what like they were like come on
easy
oh yeah I think my name was Easy Rider
[Laughter]
[Music]
because we were part of Harley's Angels
so one of the trainers thug was her
Peggy was her real name thug was gonna
be the leader and then me and this other
girl we're gonna be her backup because
she was like I'll do all the fight she's
gonna do all the talking oh yeah so and
the other girl was pretty decent athlete
so I was like [ __ ] I really just got
hired as the clown on this like of this
[ __ ] Tyler so I tried to keep up with
the training they put me on a diet a
ridiculous [ __ ] diet they were like
this will help your muscles I lost 30
pounds already I was a hundred and
twelve pounds and they were like hi easy
you have an eating disorder I go you're
making me [ __ ] beans and [ __ ] I never
Beast when they said get beans I bought
baked beans you're like no [ __ ]
kid would be like oh it's kidneys the
[ __ ] is wrong with you yeah we what's
affordable the big thing at the Campbell
the big giant can last us a while so I
mean they they went let me read me so
after they were like okay you don't have
to do the diet and then I kind of came
back to life but I really was like a
waif I look discussing okay
I used to make fun of me because I'd be
waiting tables and my pants would be
falling down because I was still waiting
how would you do this for we did one
season and then David thought that he
got enough heat behind it that we could
do a pay-per-view uh-huh yes you have to
have views paper views and so he we did
a cage match and it got real ugly scared
like they were gearing it towards little
girls and then when they did that Selena
and Peggy are pros and they wrestle in
Japan and do you know they know how to
make the blood and make it a you know
crazy and they did that and then the the
investors pulled out so we were only on
for two seasons
[Laughter]
I believe so wait so you get the job and
then talk tell me about your first match
like what happened did you do yeah I
total do you think over 20 no probably
yeah cuz we were in a lot because I used
to get a lot of bonuses and stuff
because we were they loved how I would
[ __ ] with the audience and talk [ __ ] to
people but that's just what I started
it's the form and angle what it was
packed they would pack that compact and
they would have easy signs and I'm like
[ __ ] easy size but they because I
would talk so much [ __ ] yeah so now all
everybody at the Comedy Store would come
and I I was getting like you know I'm
again I'm a street fighter so we're
training I was trying to learn you know
everything in wrestling is to the left
which is good if you're not a lefty but
I'm a righty but it was just like I
would get confused I couldn't it was
hard to train your body that way so I
kept getting hit hard because I would go
to the right instead of and so I'd have
a black eye I had a hairline fracture my
collarbone yeah yeah one of my fights I
did a huge bump not cocaine but I did a
huge back boom and I hit pyro and it cut
my head what's pyro a little thing it
would shoot out and I hit the little
and it cut my head and I was like [ __ ]
so I had a wrestling my hair was caked
cuz you know when you cut your head it
just bleeds a lot
so the the makeup lady was like we're
gonna have to fix it after
so she's just combed my hair over so
like matting holding can't be good but
yes then I also was Mitzi shore the
owner of the Comedy Store his assistant
at the time and I remember I go in I'd
have a black eye Mitzi would be like
waking up in and I'm like oh no
Ultimates remember I told you I'm doing
that wrestling show honey you don't have
to hide it from me okay oh no no no I'm
joy and I'm like look at this bruise and
I show her another but Jesus Christ what
is he doing she was so [ __ ] angry she
didn't believe me I had to bring
pictures and I'll show her like look cuz
you know there's no video recording and
then I made her watch the show but we
trained for so long before we started
filming so that was a hard part yeah to
prove it to her and then she was like
Jesus honey you're gonna kill yourself
so she hated it but all the door guys
would come and so your first match is at
the Forum mm-hmm I'm trying to think who
my first match was oh I think it was
with Becky the farmer's daughter this is
my life you're laughing
we have Becky it was a tag team it was
okay wait I just have one more question
before I go Billy
okay so you were what you started just
talking a lot of [ __ ] then what
would get challenged after that and
that's what eventually got you in the
ring to wrestle well I think what would
what it would be is that they set up the
matches you know what I mean and then I
get in there and whomever were fighting
or whatever I have to talk trash about
we are improvising oh yeah there was a
writer and I believe he was a writer for
the glow girls too because I watched the
documentary before I actually watched
the Netflix series because I was like I
never watched glow my little sister
watched I didn't pay attention to that I
was again I was kind of anti that's a
girl thing yeah I don't want that [ __ ]
you know a man I like the dudes I
maybe because of my hoe but it was so I
never really watched it so I said let me
watch check it out and the guy I saw
that [ __ ] weirdo on there and he
would come up with his comb-over and his
velcro shoes and he'd be like hey I
wrote this for you and he goes this was
really funny and I read it and I feel
like who told you that was funny
like what where did you this is the
worst I've ever talking [ __ ] to the guy
I'm sick now what i recording yet so and
then when David came he's like AZ are
you giving him a hard time and I'm like
David have you seen what hero I'm this
is horrendous
no one would say this this is not funny
I go any minute he easy he did a lot of
writing I go okay okay I'll say it
and then the night we're filming I
changed everything and I would tell the
girls to and the girls would just go
with it like barely [ __ ] him were you
tight with all the girls yeah was any of
them that you liked had beef with no I
still have I mean I shouldn't say that
because you know we're supposed to mmm
you know keep our rivals rivals whatever
but how long you in the contract I'm not
anymore but I still do commentary and so
when I do commentary sometimes Selena
majors will be in the ring and I'm like
[Laughter]
wait so your first match for tag-team
match yes it was me and Charlie Davidson
are you nervous as hell for that oh my
god yeah but like I I mean like I said
I'm stage background you know to me and
I'm like oh this is just another part
and did they do it just like WWF back in
the day only they it was dark in the
crowd and just the light on the ring or
a little bit of light it might have been
a little bit more light and I remember I
got in trouble for this my very first
match I came out and I high-fived
everybody and they were like you're a
heel you can't do that and I'm like oh
yeah so then let's go from one already
[ __ ] yeah they just left it in there
they didn't but we the two girls that I
loved wrestling this is gonna sound so
bad and racist but they were called
caged Heat and they were well miss black
one was Mexican and they escaped from
prison it was that the writers [ __ ]
we were white-trash bikers so it was all
oh yeah so but these girls were my
favorite to wrestle with because we
really hit each other we beat this [ __ ]
out of it in fact our tag team for the
belt is David McLean said it's one of
the best was wrestling you had a title
that we ever had yeah really he said
ever even from Louis no I didn't know
did you get pinned over your partner I
got my ass kicked because Charlie what
if we said [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm gonna flip
it and take this belt well Kyah this
would happen is weird cuz my family came
out my brother Johnny came out Tommy
came out Edie
mother-in-law Michelle yeah and they
were all saying in my two bedroom
apartment we and they made like
everybody came out Tommy made all these
gorgeous signs I have some killer things
that he made me Easy Rider like a
motorcycle out of paper mache and it's
awesome so they made this I still have
all of the sausage let me do the ask
what song did you come out to welcome to
my nightmare
no I'm kidding I it was it was just some
kind of like revved up it wasn't a real
it was like something they made up
because you couldn't get licensing no
way so it was just like revving came out
on a Charlie David yeah I remember joe
rogan came with his now wife and his
favorite part was the vignettes we did
was we're in a biker bar and I'm like
flirting with this guy and then I take a
cue ball and I squash it and put the
Dustin it was so bad it was good but
yeah they would come to all the matches
like when we did the live shows
everybody from the store would come my
sister I remember my little sister Edie
my brother Johnny Tommy and Michelle and
they're all
I got them like front row and I'm
getting my ass kicked it's this that's
the little thing you saw from that okay
I did have a shining a few shining
moments in the beginning but my partner
really hurt her back so I had to do most
of that fight he was like nah girl but
it was it was already how would you how
do you get my setup that way because she
was hurt prior to this she got hurt in
practice so it was like [ __ ] so we had
to change everything so I was getting
beat up so bad if you watch it it looks
like I may or may not have passed away
like there was a while where I was just
resting cuz I was like I don't care
about my sister I remember I'm getting
my ass kicked and I remember looking at
Edie and she was like what the [ __ ] like
they were getting angry like et cuz I
almost went in that ring I'm like oh
we're tight you can't let one carry
gonna get beat up we all show up
how long were like you in between fights
what do you mean like like was it
monthly weekly it was monthly yeah we
did monthly but we trained every day and
we would train for three hours a day and
I wrestled in jeans it was a full-time
job yeah oh yeah jeans of course I was
in [ __ ] jeans so I remember like
after Georgia
come on man eternity I just had a
flashback I was a kid why can I get
Georgia we can't afford those knock it
off alright Lee's no tough skin stuff
yeah you cannot rip those jeans they are
not whatever but anyway so we were when
I would walk up the ramp and you know go
behind the scenes and go backstage I
would just pull my pants down and walked
it and all the crew guys were like oh
okay okay
I wasn't one of the hot girls she's a
baby g-string did you ever do was it
always tag-team or do you ever have a
one-on-one man I did have a one-on-one
with Selena majors that was sure
amazing Selena majors and she was also
our trainer so she well she's my she's
our biggest rival and her thug of fight
four years so it was I was fighting her
she wanted to fight us all fair and
square like beat us all so the coke a
it's me and Selena this is the storyline
whatever and Selena is also doing all
the matches for everybody else so every
time that case Lena what's our match
gonna look like don't worry you'll be
fine
well what just you know go running and I
go run in or take a nice bath or weights
or whatever I you know training and I
come back hey Selena do we have a match
yet easy I'm just gonna call it you'll
be fine what you're gonna call it this
is like my third match she's calling it
so she's whispering it in my ear I
naturally go to the right eye everything
is where I do everything wrong Selena
like you got this just be confident oh
my god she hit me with a chair and I had
a flashback it's a child and I went to
grab it instead of take it and I broke
my pinkie because I went to the wrong
side I got a hairline fracture my
collarbone like everything went wrong
that fight but it looked okay right yeah
I got mine for real yeah yeah that was
the black eye match that was everything
happened let's keep her attack team yeah
they're screaming chanting and she's
whispering in my ear what to do so wait
did you the DDT
I did not not that was something Charlie
and I would do it the double duty that
was our oh you have - yeah that's what
go crazy shove it on one person or level
at same time to both people like see
that would have been a double one if I
can remember correctly yeah we did it
Bronco Billy was from Maryland oh he's
from Baltimore I love her
Lisa girl Lisa Danielle's are two first
names but she's pulling [ __ ] she was
funny she was one of my favorite people
she was yeah there was a lot of girls
that I still stay close with wait so
when you a now
now where are those fights uh those we
did them at the Belasco downtown those
girls I gotta be honest like I felt like
it's part of an athlete like I don't I
didn't feel like a ho laughs these girls
are underground like they've been doing
it for a long time they're excellent
really like I'm waddling Jesus Christ
these are real like they really know
what they're doing I'm impressed there's
things you said 99 mm it's still going
poorly or did make a resurgent it made a
resurgence yeah he he lost some money he
had to rebuilt do some stuff and you
know who's a partner with her now is
Jeanie buss and Jeanie buzz [ __ ]
yeah Jean used to come to all the
matches and she was like Easy Rider
you're one of my favorites but just was
I talk [ __ ] you know like I didn't want
to tell her I don't like the lakes but
yeah I'd wear my Celtic shirts and she
would get the idea but she was like
she's still a part of it she's still
like wow big into it and so when we it
was weird cuz the last one we did was
probably in April or May something like
that and Jeannie was there and Sylvester
Stallone's mom she's 95 yeah she fought
her hip her dentures came out it was
ugly but she yeah cuz she used to be
part of it the glow girls she was part
of that back in the day I didn't know I
was like oh [ __ ] I forgot but I didn't
watch
I would I would of course I would know
my mother Alice involved right so you
got a title match you never won never
won no we got cancelled after that so
I'm still waiting do they bring you guys
back for does anybody even remember you
all for the nostalgic yeah Selina still
fights a jungle girl who is amazing
what's going on Casey where do you wanna
be's and share yes they are the same
story very they built a lot of pain
that's her name delta name dealt a lot
of pain I'm so mad at myself you guys
like how about that dude if you look
that match up it's so good like those
girls are we're amazing like they made
me look good because they were so good
but they still and jungle girl owns a
gym in Virginia or something
her real name is Erica [ __ ] I can't
think of her last name but she is
amazing it's called endorphins and it's
a I mean her body is ridiculous like she
were the same age and I'm like how the
[ __ ] do you look like that because I
wasn't smoking yes she looks ridiculous
like she still wrestles and she still is
just as athletic as she was 17 years ago
that's like I envy her i watch her I'm
like this [ __ ] yeah she flipped off a
ladder ones like she's ridiculous but
did she ever football reporter three
bumps Erica Porter though she's amazing
if you're Virginia go to her gym she's
awesome she does love it she puts on
these videos these videos up and I'm
like I get it you want me to work out
I'm not doing here I do work out but not
like that
yeah I tried it actually I'm pretty sure
when we did the main room together you
were doing dips in the green room you
would just come from the gym that's
anger issues have to work them out but
the the dip started when I first started
doing stand-up I would get nervous and
then it became a habit like just like
okay warm up kind of get yourself like
you're going in the ring and then I was
like after a while I realized oh I'm
offending a lot of people so it'd be
better if I'm warmed up if a fight
breaks out gonna mean they don't break
any bones that way good guy got warm you
pinky right yeah
take the chair home I was warm that day
god damn pinky she got me
she got me this has been so much [ __ ]
fun oh you got to come back yeah yeah
you have let's see what the responses
will you please one more time promote
your social media I am the co-host of
The Comedy Store Live cast we also are
on all things comedy yes Rick Ingraham
and I are the host and we get a lot of
trouble so we have a disclaimer on ours
let's have a disclaimer no no I don't
know maybe nobody yelled at you guys
oh no yeah we got in trouble for
dropping some names and talking some
[ __ ] but oh well what can you do yeah
it's too bad horse be horse so here we
are and I'm doing social media right so
it's all sure yeah when a website your
Twitter or whatever you wherever you
promote your stuff okay I grew up in a
typewriter store so yeah sure yeah EJ
kerrigan is my is that the handle yeah
I'm not good at this [ __ ] I suck at it I
do have a website and I think it's
Eleanor Jake arrogant or EJ Carrie go
great
Elinor Jay Carrie go one of those it's
all one of those [ __ ] pages they'll
figure it out please please figure this
is a lot of fun I'm sure they're gonna
want to figure out after this thank you
so much for coming on this has been a
lot of fun
thank you yeah as always Jay Larson call
me calm Jay Larson comedy on all social
media ryan social media AJ Kerrigan on
all social media Elinor's Jake Aragon
talk till next Tuesday